Lauren is with us in Kansas hey Lauren
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
thank you for taking my call and for
your ministry well thank you how can I
help
well my husband and I and we are in baby
step number four we have no debt except
for a mortgage on our house in the city
and we have a loan on 62 acres just
outside the city and we have been fading
like crazy to build a house on these 62
acres without taking out a loan my
question to you is how much would you
recommend us spending on this house
would you recommend us spending all that
we have saved except for our emergency
fund or leaving some money to be able to
invest in stocks or cattle or another
Avenue what's your household income our
household income is about a hundred and
fifty thousand how much are you talking
about saving for the land to build with
I'm sorry so if we were to build kind of
closer to our dream house we would be
thinking about about 300 to 350 and how
much do you have saved so far we have
four hundred and thirty thousand dollars
saved so far so why haven't you broken
ground I'm trying to put plans together
and trying to decide on how much money
to put towards it okay
way to go Wow how old do you guess my
husband is 31 and I am 27 you're amazing
well done and is the land paid for no we
have we have a loan on the land we have
a loan for a hundred and ninety thousand
left in the land and then we have a
house loan with 160 thousand left on
your home that you're living in today
yes that we would sell and hopefully
then pay off the farm as well and it
would bring enough you think it'd bring
you a hundred ninety into your pocket
close to that and so we are hoping to
not to spend a little bit less on
building
how so that we would be completely
debt-free at the end of this process
yeah okay
so you're talking about a budget of well
you've got you one more time you've got
four hundred and what saved we have
about four hundred and thirty thousand
saved and your dream house is 350 yes
why wouldn't you build your dream house
eighty thousand you autumn what's the
equity in your current home what's your
home worth um so our home is worth about
three three hundred thousand and we have
left on the home loans one hundred and
sixty and we're still trying to leave
about three to six months which for my
husband and I had bought fifty thousand
dollars we would like to keep in savings
and not spend that well you got that for
thirty - 350 is 80 so our question is
whether or not we should yes we thing to
get to the yes build your dream house
okay because here's the thing by the
time you get it finished it'll no longer
be your dream house no one no one keeps
the same dreams unless you're dead so
this idea that you're going to build a
forever house is mythology you will
never live a very very few people live
their entire lives in one house it's
highly statistically unlikely your life
will change and you will change the kids
will grow up the grandkids will come
along the dogs will die the kiddies will
run off all this kind of stuff it
happens right and you know the what you
call a dream house will change suddenly
it'll be a two-bedroom bungalow on the
beach somewhere
or in the mountains or something right
when you and you'll be 70 it'll happen
in an eye blink so enjoy this you've
done a wonderful job you're not only
going to pay cash for the build you're
going to pay off the land when you move
into the building your house sells I
love this okay and there's nothing to
say that with no house payments anywhere
that you to wild animal savers you save
like maniacs are not gonna be able to
save enough to build up and do some work
on the farm and put some cattle on the
farm and do all that you'll be able to
do all of that with no house payments
okay won't you I mean ink spell you
cashflow tall this is what's not an
inheritance right
no this was cash flow at all of this
okay yes and so how long does it take
you to do it again with no house payment
not any time at all you're not you're
not even 30 right okay here's the
problem sometimes I think I am hearing
that both of you are excellent savers
both of you yes that's correct
yeah sometimes savers have trouble
enjoying their money and sometimes you
need someone like me to say we're living
like no one else so later we can live
and give like no one else you have paid
the price you paid for the ticket go to
the show okay okay oh thank you Dave
you've done great I'm proud of you